I didn't want to give you this in front
of everyone it's an antique advent
calendar it was your grandmother's she
wanted you to have it right I've never
seen you without a mouthful of cookies
[Music]
he's been away just friends okay what's
going on with you we would travel in the
world taking photos dating interesting
people well I've been too scared to
leave my crappy day job I want to be
fearless enough to go after my dreams
like you what do you think will happen
if you just live for probably get some
of these questions about my future
answered that's a Christmas wish
that's my regular wish
[Music]
that's this you pair boots a calendar
gave me boots crazy right clearly the
calendars matter clearly I've got a
Christmas tree toy and then of a car ran
over a Christmas tree it's my fault the
guy at the tree farm recommended bungee
cords not twine yeah well there's a
reason why twine jumping never caught on
Gramps that calendar is just a calendar
right
hey you look familiar by any chance did
you murder my tree with your car you
look happy
I have a date with Ty tonight
what's up without you there's a guy they
thought you were the guy I'm gonna
friend friends outside
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
your grandmother was convinced at at
magical powers
she said it brought her to me
[Music]
[Applause]
it's calendar what did you predict today
I don't know I decided to risk it the
not Chuck interesting strategy
you
[Music]
[Applause]
you